do you think about mortality your own
mortality yes because there's a three
elements to that one like a normal
person and I think about that especially
in relation with parents when you lost
your dad
yes and mom also so you know you you
cannot let something which happened to
everybody at some point when you lose
your father and mother you understand
that now it's you you're next
that's into its well that's human the
second element what I think about is
religion because at least for me but for
many people also like going to beliefs
of your parents grandparents etc helps
helps and you start to understand the
older you are the closer you are to this
moment the more you just feel it's or
all of the religion is huge and number
three I'm a scientist and a couple of
weeks ago we had a long discussion on
the conference
about immortality at the worth of this
cosmetic meaning because I mentioned to
you that with this LVMH like a Louboutin
or whether um and Hennessy that's the
important one and then sporty one we
have been talking about like a
possibility to change direction of Aging
and this is one of challenges which
actually in the beginner of plasma
medicine we start trying to do it was
like a kind of serious experiments
trying to using plasma tool to determine
aging process I can explain you more
details but it's a longer story but as a
result of this experiments unfortunately
we show that in a hundred percent of
like experiments we did we actually
accelerated aging not but maybe you have
two other ideas you might be able to
from a scientific perspective there is
there is some shirt because you know
that mortality it just God's cruel major
put it in us this mortality in which way
we have stem cells and they just you
know providing differentiation which is
like a renovation of us like when there
is a tiny small kid he changed his no
siren on each couple of days so just
it's it's always like a generation of
the tissue
yes doesn't birth doesn't birth yeah it
is not like it's not like it knows is
like growing no it's just as each time
have a new one now when in your age
like liquefying it happened less often
maybe once in I don't know five ten
years but for me fortunately
unfortunately like I will stay with this
nose forever now so the only thing we
have to do actually is just to and this
self themselves they're still there we
just but their efficiency is for some
not very much known reason went down
down down down down down so what we have
to do we have to actually help this stem
cells stimulate them just to become
again more active and if we do that and
plus medicines right then just you know
instead of getting older and we will go
back younger and younger
is it possible yes it's against rule of
nature no so this is third way to think
about that but that's a really challenge
interesting that it was discussion on
this subject with leave it on if science
does arrive at a breaker if you could
live forever would you would you like to
live forever I think yes I would try why
not you know let's well I'll give you a
reason not is it makes a life you know
the fact that stuff ends gives it some
deep meaning you know Jewish people
basically they are deeply deeply deeply
in love with life you know they say
Lehigh to life so Jewish people they
actually believe that God gave us life
to enjoy what will happen we'll have
another life or not or maybe it will be
like again we'll be young
is it possible the Jewish answer is
absolutely clear we don't know so but
enjoying life it's the law
absolute law so if you have possibility
to leave you have to go on with life
that's a Jewish answer and I like it
are you afraid of death yes oh you
remember when you asked me how long did
it take for me to to fall in love with
with your mother 1 2 3 yeah yeah yeah
you answered that pretty quickly so what
do you think is the meaning of life
that's a difficult question you you
never like this the silly questions
go back to your eighth grade self and be
romantic for Sutton yeah what's the
meaning of life
yeah meaning of our existence here on
this little planet well I remember that
I kept asking myself this question when
I was an eighth grade it was one of the
crucial question for me Oh at that time
by the exactly the same time when I roll
this romantic stuff and at that time I
remember my answer I kept saying day by
day which means the meaning of life is
just to enjoy enjoy today's life and go
to tomorrow
survive the day enjoy the day and you
know your French existentialist your yes
archery and yes sir
it's but you know at that time I didn't
have any knowledge about exist sure
lists whatever starter yeah special
starter um but I was absolution about
that if you ask me now I would say I was
right I I thought I thought that was a
natural extension of the axiom which is
I'm always right yes yes yes but you
know in each joke it's a 50% of joke if
you present not but after reading it was
a book limo words right what's in
English you say soccer sorry
limo words slower I think in this book
he just when I read that it's basically
absolutely bad book fleet
yes archers I prefer Camus and the other
French guy yeah I just decided that I am
I was not alone with this kind of ideas
yeah there's other French guys what do
you hope Greg and I accomplish in life
and next I'll ask you for advice and
after that we'll drink some vodka are
you calculating I know I'm not
calculating I'm just trying to recall a
very nice poetry you know between I I
love Russian poetry and it's interesting
that my favorite Russian poet it's
actually the woman it's a mini Nazi time
and she wrote like a short poetry just L
saying that she said nationalist
Universalist Paul nabina assumes a brief
Yeti scientist with a post yes way mr.
Spacely well and it is in Russian but I
am I think that it's kind of deep and
kind of smart
I wish I wish you to be happy and I know
that if I push you in some direction our
Greg
it's nothing happened like I mean I okay
I will be always recommending then your
whisper telling you and and don't forget
I'm always pushing anyway but you know
that and I have to do that because I am
a father so I will move and I'm always
pushing in conservative direction
because because I am a father and I very
much wish you to have your son my
grandson or granddaughter yeah I almost
guarantee you that we will do the same
he will not recommend your daughter to
take a risk and to go to Hollywood try
to be an actress she's supposed to do it
without without your permission
what and as and that's that's that's
beautiful who make our own way and you
always have given me a brilliant advice
that I almost never follow and usually
disagree with so but that's the way it
should be
yeah that's the way of life well so what
speaking of which what advice do you
have for me for the next 10 20 years in
life sort of in any direction you see I
am
hesitating I am thinking about I mean I
have two ideas and their time very much
: yeah
so from one hand my approach was the
same as Sartre
so just from one hand I like the idea
just to live your life and to enjoy and
to be prepared for tomorrow which
everything will be start again it's from
one hand from another hand I remember
myself in elementary school he remember
beginning of our discussion about this
stupid guys these idiots with stones and
I just had an idea just to build a
rocket to put there so I want to do that
and they did it so this is another idea
when you'll just put your heart into
something for a longer time not for one
day but you have to find your own way
just and my feeling is it to you
personally found it with artificial
intelligence and that's why my feeling
is that in your specific case my advice
will be just not to let them this idiots
with stones to succeed you have to
deliver and that's what I like and
that's what I made me dope with the
mercury in the rocket but build the
rocket it's your choice
yeah because that's a rocket which
you're building but what is important
that you
well I think this is a good time to uh
to maybe toast our family oh they do
some we thought we'll do you probably
drink more vodka but we decided to be
responsible adults and just save the
vodka to the end it's always a question
how much vodka we have to drink in
Russian tradition usually we calculate
for adults like a one bottle per one
bottle per a person
take a look at is made in Soviet Union
and it's 1986 this is what girl of my
father because in 1986 in a year of
Chernobyl
he gave this bottle a friend of mine
because this friend of mine he went to
America and he just modest my friends he
just saved this basket for us to be able
to just whatever to think about his name
of my friend oh he's Sasha but we call
him sure sure but that's the same thing
as your best friend your lifelong friend
yes it's like you're mad mad mad matter
any shoutout and first you can toast the
family but let me just toast to the best
dad I've ever had the best that I could
ever ask for I love you did yeah I love
you let's go
you